[Musique]
tout ce que vous voyez ici est envoûté
mouvante et où a été utilisé pour toutes
sortes de pratiques rituelles aucun
jouer là dedans il est plus prudent que
ces objets soient ici plutôt qu'ailleurs
parfois il vaut mieux laisser le génie
dans la lampe est ce que tes parents
gardent des trucs flippant chez vous
tout est enfermé dans une pièce comme ça
on est à l'abri qu il vaut mieux que
personne n'entre l'acteur
[Musique]
t'as fait quoi pour complète là
qu'est ce que tu as fait c'est sortir
qu'ils louent je suis désolé tu as
touché à quelque chose dont j'ai tous
ses atouts - ben tu dois être trompés de
maison il n'ya pas d'un label ici si
elle est là
quelquefois je vois des choses voulait
même pas soit que mama poite et josé la
poupée elle appelle d'autres esprits
[Musique]